ready I have
this week is the second anniversary of
YouTube channel the periodic table of
videos and we're all very excited its
traditional that when you have an
anniversary you give a present to your
partner in this case to our viewers and
the traditional present for the second
anniversary is cotton so we have a
sample of cotton and some things to say
about cotton to give you to celebrate
our anniversary okay so what we're doing
today is Neal has made of some gun
cotton which is ordinary cotton wool
that you treat with a mixture of nitric
acid and sulfuric acid and hopefully
we're gonna get something that's gonna
go up in flames
pretty pretty well have a look at my tie
and you can see on here are some rings
with five carbons and an oxygen and
these rings represent glucose the
unusual thing about glucose is that the
rings of glucose can join together if
you join two rings together you get
sugar these rings can join together to
make very long chains and depending how
they join together they can make either
cellulose or starch what happens in
cellulose is that you have these rings
that are joined together and these
chains in the plant like in cotton line
up together and cotton the fibers of
cotton and made out of cellulose and the
reason why chemists get excited about
cellulose is because these rings have
joined the carbon atoms
OAH groups and the OAH groups react
quite easily so you can take something
else and react it on to be various
chains and one of the things that
chemists like to react with it are is
nitric acid which puts on nitro groups
okay so Neil's gonna come here with our
match on a stick and set fire to the
cotton wall we'll see what happens what
the nitro groups do is to make the
cellulose burn really well so called gun
cotton whoa that's pretty impressive so
I think that was quite a vigorous
reaction I don't know if you've ever
thought about this but if you have one
of these really big guns like they used
to have on battleships you need an
explosive to push the shell up the gun
barrel and out but the shell is really
heavy so if you have an explosive like
dynamite that goes bang very quickly the
shell doesn't have time to move and
you'll just blow up the whole gun and so
you'll destroy your ship but you won't
shoot at the enemy but gun cotton burns
nice and steadily so the pressure builds
up and it accelerates the shell out of
the gun the other thing is that when
this nitrocellulose was first discovered
in the 19th century people got really
very excited because they could dissolve
the nitrocellulose in a variety of
organic solvents
you can't dissolve that cotton not
easily anyway and they discovered they
had this material nitrocellulose which
they could dissolve up and then they
could evaporate the solvent and make all
sorts of objects and the first thing
they discovered they could make was
something that looked very like ivory
this is ivory from an elephant I should
say straight away that I didn't buy this
I got this a long time ago and although
one shouldn't have ivory it seems unfair
to the elephant to throw this away but
you can make artificial ivory or what
looks like ivory they used to make
billiard balls for pool and for
billiards out of nitrocellulose the same
material that you use for propelling
shells and guns so fortunately stable
enough that when you have a good shot
and the balls hit each other they don't
go bang but they must have burnt quite
fiercely if the house caught fire a
billiard ball still may out of
nitrocellulose no billiard balls are now
made out of plastic